hello there citizens of the reject me
hello there Citizens
We're gonna watch uh episode four of
tales of the Jedi I believe this is the
longest one they have 45 minutes this
one is two hours two hours could have
been a full-length feature film but here
we are joined by Michael B Michael
business is the kids on the streets of
Harlem call them Omni media check out
his channel awesome reaction Channel
Michael how are you you've been enjoying
tales as a Jedi I have it's been really
intriguing so far we had one Ahsoka two
dookus and I'm ready for more of the
same I don't know we'll find out next
time on Dragon Ball Z
it's been a little bit more uh
serialized than I expected especially
with the Dooku storyline I was like oh
yeah it's not like you know take days
later but there's a there's definitely a
specific story they're actually telling
I thought it would just be like pure
anthology
that's what I kind of thought too but uh
it definitely built off of the one we
watched before yeah
um and I'm I'm wondering I'm I'm just
kind of curious we had two dookus back
to back I wonder what the next one's
gonna be very curious yeah yeah it'll be
a Sarge Ventress
um all right guys well uh leave a like
subscribe and also uh you could support
us on patreon we get the rash and watch
alongs there let's get to it
[Music]
good
it's like poetry Rhymes they should add
that to the intro every time it says
lucasfilm it's like poetry right it's
just a insane
poetry rhymes
again core side you greedy sons of
[ __ ] only looking out for yourselves
[Music]
dude with a longer longer beard
this is just the story of Dooku's beard
yeah it's the it's a Serpico story yeah
how much time has passed
please enter security clearance code
is the same button three times deleting
oh my God
now archive data
deleted wow
plans in effect it's his fault a bunch
of children are gonna cost Obi-Wan later
Michael yes
it would seem he has encountered a Sith
Lord
or so he claimed to the Jedi
where was this encounter
tattooing I was taking place during
episode one Seattle
[Music]
yeah
oh nice I encountered a highly skilled
Warrior one obviously trained in the
jedale yards
[Music]
this Lord is not to be trifled with and
I will not be there to protect you
Obi-Wan fills that role now
he acquits himself quite well
that's good
I should like to meet him someday oh you
will many times many times too they grow
up so fast
our students I must take my leave
she can sense the darkness within him I
mean he must be just meeting yeah like
she also just mysteriously disappears
between movies at one point the Sith
Lord
uh I used to bring quite long here as a
boy
fascinated with this tree having been
born here on coruscants
so there's leaving for Naboo
the funeral is to be held there
oh got it
Qui-Gon Jinn has become one with the
force
it is time to let him go
and you can do this
what choice have I oh that is
interesting
feels like one of his final dark pushes
was the death of Qui-Gon that's
fascinating it makes me think back to
because like you know when he captures
Obi-Wan
he tries to recruit him I do really like
the music a lot it's real Sci-Fi tune to
it
followed
is this why she disappears
dude
beautiful this is yeah man
[Music]
Coruscant on the the Twilight this is
the first episode I have like and or
Vibes yeah
this is where we saw him meet Sidious at
the end of uh
attack
oh no
[Music]
it's really difficult to stealthily
follow someone with a ship you know yeah
you've gone too far
doing don't know what you mean you know
exactly what it means
you allowed Maul to kill him
you lost an apprentice and so did I
all in service of our greater goals
the Galaxy would not be remarried
without sacrifice wow man you question
my loyalty
always
you have been loyal to a greater cause
how many have died because of my actions
such is the price of freedom
no no no no this is so foreboding so I
have been betrayed no
I will kick her away oh he's gonna have
don't believe her
whatever lies he's told you
whatever you have done
you can make up for it now by bringing
him to Justice oh this is so sad the
Jedi blindly serve a corrupt Senate that
failed the Republic it represents
you want to prove your loyalty
killer
goddamn Palpatine
uh the devil and the angel man I'm
afraid it is too late
[Music]
[Music]
yes
damn this is crazy how tragic this is
for uh Dooku
after a point he can't go back are you
he doesn't believe he can go back quiet
gone did not have to die
so you kind of Hope Dooku oh dude
this music man yeah it's beautiful
[Music]
oh my
God oh what a way to go out God damn
you have done well my Apprentice
screw you Palpatine
rise
my friend
master
oh oh [ __ ]
boss move
[Music]
no he's looking at the light
[Music]
this is so heartbreaking I don't think
I've ever felt so bad for Dooku or
yaddle
so many have suffered for what you call
order
let me give you
jeez wow
[Music]
well I got like chills everywhere
oh my spot doesn't like that man
this is really this is really well done
you know
before we started uh Michael and I were
talking about how we heard some opinions
out there people were just being like
yeah it's fine
it's there's kind of like the writer
right through here I'm like no it's fine
that's what we heard some opinions like
oh Eric I only heard like a couple yeah
they're people really associated with
the Star Wars Community but I think
these are dunce like we're more than
we're we're two-thirds of the way
through it and I'm like this is really
well done like this is this is
incredibly done I think uh this is
brilliant man yeah this is amazing this
is It's So effective and and
um
it's such a great mood to it and
like I did not expect walking in here I
thought at most I'd be like okay yeah
it's kind of interesting to see what
happened with Dooku but to really feel
for the downfall here yeah
um like there's such pathos to it all
and
with the adult too like obviously that
fight's gonna be compared to you know
Yoda and him an attack of the Clones and
while that fight is a lot more exciting
because it's like you're out of fighting
and it's it's so cathartic and he's like
flipping around like a madman
that's what I think it's like he's gone
crazy he's flipping all over the place
uh
there this this fight had so much
emotion to it though so in a lot of ways
I prefer it because because of the fact
that there's such there's such emotional
weight and there's a fight for a man's
Soul right now
and you just know the inevitable that's
not gonna pan out with how she intends
and there's frames so
just so
perfectly the whole time too like she
could sense what's going on in his head
like because every time he's what in a
moment of vulnerability we see yaddle
there like exactly
trying to like kind of I don't know like
keep an eye over him not like watch him
or be like you know not from like a
point of like
uh fear or anything like that or
whatever it was always concern and
compassion for her like it's not the way
Mace Windu would watch her watch him he
would be like am I gonna have to cut it
I have to cut his head
right now and she's just like she's
there at every step of the way with open
arms yeah like willing probably more
than willing to have heard him out if he
ever expressed his concerns but he he's
so
distanced at this point and from what we
see he's already gone down the path to
start actually it's no more it's no
longer
just feelings
he's committed to actions by this point
yeah he's done things despite the kind
of conflict despite the fact that he he
hasn't in his heart he still questions
things but even like and you know what
this really did as much time as we've
spent with Palpatine
in so many so like he's been around
forever you know so it's been so much
time with this Palpatine guy
and I'll be honest this was like the
first time I found myself actually
mad at him in a scene if that makes
sense I was like I can kind of agree I
was like just like a short way because
like we just like and maybe that's part
of why like the time we've spent with
Dooku up to this point yeah partially
where I was like I am so you're you're
pissing me off so much dude I was like
there's like a couple times like you
know equipped for the reaction and stuff
every now and then but whatever there
was like a moment there where I I like
physically stopped myself from being
like shut the [ __ ] up yeah no he got
yeah it was it was actually uh
guys as much like manipulating and
whatever that we've seen Palpatine do in
this particular the immediacy of the
emotions of this this moment in time I
was like wow I'm actually like really
mad at Palpatine or anything and I've
never felt that I've never been
uh like upset at what he's doing so I
thought that was effective It's very
effective it's like this was a really
Sinister episode and I like the I like
the uh how they're actually all
connected and you do see like we don't
need to see how him and like it'd be
cool to see how we met Palpatine how he
like got acquainted with him and stuff
and yeah how this journey began you know
yeah I would like to kind of I'm curious
how Palpatine reached out I don't
remember if that got touched on via
phone call
you're like hey man uh I saw you know
got your email I saw you on LinkedIn
yeah
some interesting things to say
the uh well I think what they're doing
more than focusing on on like like while
there's plot points obviously they're
focusing on the emotional turning points
for you the most that's that's what it's
that's what the plot points are going to
serve is the emotion and I think like
even with the music choices that they
have and the way they choose to capture
each specific episode it's it's imbued
in the emotion so much and and I feel
like that's what makes it so easy to
connect to and so quickly
that like I'll be on like Dooku's always
been like a cool character to me but
I've never yeah I've never really been
one to be like
what's his origin like I want to see
what happens yeah I uh just in
preparation for this honestly is where
I've gotten really intrigued by his
character in a way that I have not been
um because like he's cool in the Clone
Wars and they do
you do I get the sense that when he's
introduced an attack of the Clones that
there was a point where
I could feel like there was a point
where he probably believed in his
Crusade
um but like but you didn't really dive
into it at all and you just kind of
forget about it like once he starts
fighting Yoda and Anakin Obi and all
that stuff like it's just like a
momentary okay well as much as like
characters have downfalls with the
tragic downfalls where they turn to the
dark side this is that rare instance
where I'm like I really get why he
turned to the dark side like it really
it really makes sense to me
because there's a version of this where
you're like I can't really come from
us might be a hot thing I don't know
it makes way more sense than Anakin
turned turning definitely no I I will I
will back you I will back you 100
um but like it's almost a very similar
beat sure you know when he
Palpatine also there being his little
shit-eating grin self
when Anakin cut off mace's hand and he
was like oh well I guess there's no
going back
it was like we kind of had a little bit
of a moment there with the with the
Great
when the grape actually fell on yaddle I
think like at the moment when he
realized like oh wait did this just
happen even though it didn't yet I think
at that point
he was like okay well I guess I gotta
commit now yeah but it was it was
honestly it was more effectively done
than that same scene in Revenge of the
Sith as much as I love that movie man
but it's not for the
the art
that's my favorite of the three
obviously
um for many people too but
yeah I think this I think this has done
so well that with with people who have
just been like it's fine it's not
necessary I'm like I don't know man this
is like great dude like this is really
dude could you imagine if the prequels
was like this yeah this was the story
this is this is great stuff I I'm really
really on on a very like the first
episode with the Soca which I do find to
be an interesting choice because Ahsoka
is obviously can't I mean I don't really
know how Ahsoka ages but that has got to
be after a lot of this because Anakin is
not even in the picture yet right well
he is as like as Jake Lloyd but yeah um
in this episode uh but you know so I'm
like that's a that's an interesting
choice and I like that episode
um but yeah obviously the real like whoa
this is truly gripping
um as a term with the Dooku side so yeah
I mean we gotta move on to five and six
but
I don't know I have an idea of where
this might be going but we'll talk about
it when we get to it yeah because I I
feel like there is I think these are
well Justified I think it's existence is
well Justified
I'm honestly a little disappointed that
there's only two more of these left
yeah they could have made a real series
out of the Dooku storyline it's been so
compelling it's been very compelling
um but I also like the chunks and uh and
the time jumps and stuff uh they
actually
and it helps you like if you're a little
acquainted but yeah this this has so
much more layers to Dooku um make it
make for an interesting experience when
going back through clone wars and
whenever you see Dooku you know because
he anyway uh yeah let's move on episode
five
oh yeah
but guys uh what'd you think leave a
like subscribe click that Bell follow
Michael on his uh YouTube page
and uh we'll talk soon
talk soon talk to you say hi to your
mother for me
[Music]